we just heard from gary neville um i
think you were listening into the
interview
i just want to read what he said to you
in full about
labour abstaining on that vote on covert
restriction tears he said
when you're elected and you're in that
seat in westminster you take a position
you don't abstain you take part in the
match you're the opposition
don't sit in the stand he's right isn't
he
labour did sit on the stand
no i respectfully disagree with that
analysis we didn't sit in the stands at
all what we did
was to act in the national interest we
accepted first of all that there should
be
restrictions that's why we didn't oppose
them
but at the same time there were still
issues
so for example there wasn't a
comprehensive
health and indeed economic strategy
alongside the restrictions there wasn't
that communication strategy
there wasn't the strategy the effective
strategy we need
around test track and isolate and there
were substantial gaps in the economic
package
so in that situation the appropriate
thing to do was not to block the
restrictions altogether that wouldn't
have been in the national interest
but they weren't at the level where we
could give them our wholehearted support
and that's why we took the
decision to abstain it turned out to be
a very important decision
because it seemed in the numbers that
there were sufficient numbers
of conservative mps rebelling that the
prime minister has frankly lost control
of
that would have created a significant
issue you see
this is what i don't understand you say
that you were you know happy that the
legislation went through because
otherwise there wouldn't be the
restrictions in place
so why don't you just vote for it you
know some might say that trying to have
your cake and eat it here you want the
restrictions to go through you
effectively support them despite your
doubts but you also perhaps want to
reserve the right to criticize the
government if it all goes wrong
well no we also want to put pressure on
the government at the same time to
improve
what is on the table and let me just
take that example
of the economic package which clearly
has been a significant problem
for example you have a situation where
businesses are getting
as it were one-off help it doesn't
reflect
the period that areas of the country
are actually under restrictions take
areas of the north and under
restrictions
for a significantly longer period than
other parts of the country
in addition to that we want more
certainty around the furlough scheme
it's good that it was extended albeit at
the 11th hour
but we still have this threat of changes
to the scheme
in january there are also many people
who've been excluded from hell
particularly the self-employed
so we accept the need for restrictions
but we still are pushing for
improvements
because the package particularly the
economic package put forward by the
government
simply doesn't match the ambition of the
moment so you're abstained on the coved
restrictions
are you going to explain if there's a
brexit trade deal vote as well
well on the issue of the brexit
trade deal and potential trade deal my
first message is this
we absolutely need to get a deal
we all know what the consequences of no
deal would be
for the country both in terms of jobs
and livelihoods all across the united
kingdom
but also in terms of that security
partnership that we need
for access to databases and the
operation of international warrants
that allow us to keep our people safe so
absolutely first of all
we need to get a deal and that's the
strong message
in terms of our position on any deal
clearly we need to see what has been
agreed i think that's a sensible
responsible
position to take but let's very much we
hope there is a deal because there seem
to be two paths before us at the moment
a path of leaving the transition period
without a deal
and leaving with a deal and we do know
how catastrophic the no deal outcome
would be
so if a no deal would be catastrophic in
your words
and that the uk absolutely needs to get
a deal
surely the logical conclusion is that
labour is going to vote for a deal
well i think i think there's two points
there i think first of all it's the
responsible thing to actually consider
the deal that is actually agreed but in
addition to that
we don't know at the moment what's
actually going to be presented
to parliament will it be uh the dealers
agreed
will it be a piece of legislation
that is actually giving effect to that
deal in legal terms and we'll have to
uh consider that as well so those are
the questions
that we will as an opposition be
considering and in
considering those we will be putting the
national interest first
and bearing in mind how important it is
that we do actually find a way now of
leaving
with a deal no deal would be
catastrophic at any moment
but it is particularly the case as we go
through this global pandemic
you know listening to your answers you
know on the one hand on the other hand
it feels to me like abstaining is on the
table still
well look it's a question of first of
all
the government we want to get a deal
that is crucially important and that's
why it's been extremely concerning we
want all parties around the table
to reach that deal that's the first
important crucial step
the responsibility is abstaining
well look what i'm saying uh in in terms
of this
sophie is of course there are various
options when you get
any particular vote that you get before
parliament there are the
the options that there always are that's
absolutely the case but what i'm
saying is that the responsible thing to
this is first of all emphasize the need
to get a deal
but then to consider what has been
agreed but also to consider
what's actually going to be put before
parliament it may not be
a straight vote on the deal it may
actually be that time is running out
uh so much now that actually all we'll
get is an actual piece of legislation
putting that deal into effect which of
course we would look at in the way we
look at any piece of legislation
i absolutely understand that of course
you need to see
the legislation but but there is a bit
of a serious point here you know
we know there are incredibly difficult
decisions
on covid and brexit we know that there's
arguments on both sides
but that is why we elect politicians to
make
those difficult decisions you know
you've abstained
on covid it sounds like you might
abstain on brexit as well
well look we consider each particular
circumstance and i've explained why we
took the approach that we did
on the coveted restrictions that were
put before parliament
we will now look at the issue of a
brexit deal
if one is agreed putting the national
interest first which is absolutely what
a responsible opposition
should do we will then consider as i say
what has been agreed we'll then have to
consider in addition
the form in which it is put to
parliament and what's right what we're
actually being
uh asked to do and ensuring as well by
the way
that whatever scenario there is on the
31st of december that the government has
actually prepared for that
and that's something we've been pushing
in recent months and we'll continue to
push the government on as well
okay and now i'm keen to ask you well
i've got you about one other uh story in
the
newspapers this weekend and the
government's trying to deport
up to 50 jamaican nationals some of them
came here as children some of them have
family here
but they have subsequently committed
crimes in the united kingdom
is it right that convicted criminals
born overseas
should be deported
well look labour will always act in the
national
interest and if there are people who are
convicted of very serious crimes who've
lost their right
to remain then yes they should be
deported but the point that we were
raising with regard to that particular
flight
was deep concern around the windrush
scandal
and continuing injustice where of course
people have been
deported who shouldn't have been in the
past and that's why we put forward
as a labour front bench very serious
questions
of the government on the work that they
had done on this flight
for example we've put issues of someone
on the flight having a grandfather from
the windrush generation
a great aunt who may even have been on
the actual empire
wind rush so asking those questions was
extremely important and indeed we seem
to have been vindicated in asking those
questions
when it does appear that significant
numbers of people originally
meant to go on that flight did not in
the event leave on it
you bring up windrush and compare this
to windrush
i just wonder do you think some people
might see that as a bit insulting to
compare
you know the deportation of criminals
including rapists
to the attempted deportation of the
windrush generation didn't commit crimes
they came here to the uk decades ago to
work and to try and rebuild the economy
after the war economy after the war
i don't think that think that at all
there's an issue as to whether or not
there were there were people on the
flight who had eligibility for
the windrush scheme but on the broader
issue of the windrush generation the
government is piling
injustice upon injustice we've had the
promise
that the 30 recommendations in the wendy
williams lessons learned review from
march
are going to actually be implemented not
one of them has been implemented
and the windrush compensation scheme is
frankly an offensive
mess a scheme that was expected to run
into the value of hundreds of millions
of pounds
we were told last week it's paid out to
226 people and around about 2.1 million
pounds now of course
i'm pleased that those 226 people have
received at least some compensation for
the terrible injustice they've suffered
but that is a tiny tiny fraction
of the overall scale of this injustice
that scheme is unsurprisingly losing
confidence and the government
desperately needs to get a grip of it